last time you were here you told me um  you were talking about your hamster so  has your hamster had babies or anything  yes ma'am uh my  foster hamster natasha who i was taking  care of for a friend of mine who's a  breeder in virginia  recently had a litter of baby hammies oh  that's a hamster that's true  uh lady at work gave them fake oh my  goodness there they are oh  my gosh they're adorable  that's isla my god the cheeks that's my  hammy and she  is the cutest sassiest little baby if  she  if you feed her sling and she doesn't  want it she will slap your finger  she will she reaches out her little paw  and  not even kidding she just goes and she  throws food but she's adorable and  really sweet  oh my gosh i love you barely spoiled i  love the cheeks that was amazing yep i'm  still here  just waiting for you to subscribe if you  don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever  help